Big Brother Alum Melissa Lopez has got
no shame in the Hooters game I don't
know how to keep my mouth shut and if
something's bothering me it will come
out I wear my emotions on my face the
back story well Alyssa worked at the
food chain prior to doing two reality
shows Big Brother season 23. I want
Sarah Beth to think that I'm playing the
competition for her that way I can gain
some trust with her and MTV's The
Challenge
good job a Twitter user recently caught
wind of Alyssa returning to her old job
and shamed her for it on Twitter writing
quote a certain person from bb23 is back
working at Hooters but Alyssa's got
Hooters Pride the reality star shut the
hater down clapping back by asking I'm
confused why you think I should be
embarrassed by this to be able to pay my
rent from two ships at Hooters is
amazing so many reality TV stars have
actual jobs where normal human beings
I'm just real enough to to show it and
get this she even doubled down with an
invitation quote come in my next shift
I'll buy you a shot in fact Alyssa's
never been shy about her job at Hooters
she's proudly posted several snaps in
her uniform she was even featured in a
Hooters billboard in South Florida near
where she lives growing up was much
harder than most of my friends I kind of
had to grow up on my own I was
definitely independent starting at a
young age but Alyssa isn't the first
recognizable face who's taken heat for a
conventional job where's the ring
they're still in the box actually I
wasn't going to wear it until we told
both of our parents oh have you told
your parents yes we were just at my
house The Cosby Show star Jeffrey Owens
found himself in a similar position as
Alyssa after photos of him bagging
groceries at Trader Joe's went viral
when I took the job Trader Joe's um I
was I was concerned
that people would judge me reject me
look down on me I made a conscious
effort
not to let people in my industry know
about it you kind of imagine the worst
case scenario and then it was even a
little bit worse than that and before in
you knew it I mean I was just being just
loved up on in this almost embarrassing
way you know Jeffrey received a ton of
support from fans and colleagues in the
industry including Tyler Perry who at
the time cast him on his own network
drama The Haves and have-nots what was
his reaction when he was offered this
role shock and oh joy but also very
humble just see the humility of it was
was all over it he was just I just want
you to be sure you want me for this and
I want to be sure that this is something
that you want me to do so I was I was
very moved by that
this here
how are you I'm Senator Wesley
I told you I didn't want to talk to you
I only need a minute of your time I mean
most actors the vast majority of actors
do other things along with acting my
situation is a little different it's
it's not unique but it's a little more
particular than that you know I'm an
actor who actually you know at one point
was was part of the biggest show on
television seen at times by 55 plus
million people a night and for someone
like that to take a regular job that's
an extra little
you know potential awkwardness and
discomfort you know
um but yeah I mean artists
always have side almost always have side
jobs so there's nothing there's nothing
new about that
[Music]